this is a production of cornell
university
so this is a story about
nitrogen management on maize corn
and
basically research development of a tool
extension of that tool
and then recently the commercialization
of that tool
so a little bit of background about
nitrogen especially on corn
and there's kind of two components of it
of course the production the agronomic
aspect and then the environmental
component so farmers spend a lot of
money on nitration sometimes they spend
more nitrogen than they do on seed
end use efficiency
remains quite low a lot of that nitrogen
gets lost doesn't end up in the plant
there's a lot of uncertainty associated
with nitrogen management especially with
increasing weather variability
and then we have all these what we call
negative externalities
so high energy
input because of the hebrew boss process
to manufacture synthetic nitrogen
the greenhouse gas emissions very
considerable i'll show you some data on
that
and then persistent water quality
problems basically and we've been
throwing a lot of money at that for
years without really any any progress so
a little bit about you know the hypoxia
problem i'm sure you're familiar with it
so we have this dead zone basically in
the gulf of mexico that develops in the
late summer every year
and
the epa has some goals to get that down
to about 2 000 square meter miles
but we're persistently averaging about 5
000 even this year
so we're not really making any progress
uh this is
where most of it comes from you know
obviously
corn production areas especially on
poorly drained soils that have tile
drainage that causes a hydrologic
shortcut
and so the epa has uh through the gulf
hypoxia action planning goal to reduce
those losses by 45 percent
even if you get a hundred percent of the
farmers
to
really manage the nitrogen very
carefully it will be very difficult to
reach 45 percent you're never going to
be able to get 40 you know 100 of the
farmers so it's it's challenging uh the
epa is pushing it onto the states
and they each have their own goals and i
should mention of course that the
chesapeake bay very similar problem and
uh so this is not an easy problem to
address
in addition we have the greenhouse gas
emissions so nitrous oxide is the
largest
contribution from agriculture in terms
of global warming
44 methane is second carbon dioxide
third methane is probably a little
higher now that they increase the uh
ghd component uh here's a little
interesting factoid basically nitrogen
application on agricultural land has as
much of a greenhouse gas impact as the
u.s aviation industry so all the planes
that are flying around
you know have have a similar impact so
it's it's a considerable problem and
we're managing it very inefficiently
so the idea is really if we can really
match the nitrogen that the plant needs
um exactly
so we don't over fertilize and we just
provide exactly the amount that the
plant needs because it's a critical
plant nutrient and it's important for
yield
so what is the optimum nitrogen rate
well this is some data from iowa corn
after corn corn after soybean so your
optimum end rate may range from
100 to 250 actually probably 300.
okay and you can say well you know most
likely you're going to be needing this
or this amount
but you have this huge range now this is
not random
there are underlying factors of this
variability soil types especially
weather rotations especially you know et
cetera
so what adopt 10 does it aims to manage
this variability
right so that we can tell you in this
year on this field you maybe need only
about this much but in another year you
maybe need about that much so just
improved
dynamic recommendations
it's a little bit about the history so
this really goes back
into the 80s it's
a lot of people collaborated on this
even people like jeff wagonette and john
hudson for those of you have been around
for a long time so we we've been able to
take advantage of a lot of that
investment
1998 was really the idea that we
analyzed a lot of field trials
and used our model
to
to basically replicate the results of
the field trial and we did quite well so
we were able to then say well we can
turn that around we can use the model to
make better predictions
of the seasonal nitrogen needs and since
most of that variability is the result
of early season weather patterns when
you can still have an opportunity to
intervene
so maybe when the when the corn is about
this high
you have an opportunity to much to
really improve the nation
recommendations
so then we got some funding the
computational
initiative
then
about 10 years we started to
send out email recommendations through
the extension system then in 2008 we
developed what's then called the adapt
end tool and was more or less a
cloud-based tool
in 2011 we started to do extensive field
trials basically in many places many
states especially new york and iowa and
then this past year we licensed the
product and it's now been commercialized
for a startup company that company by
the end of the year will have
nine employees
so unless you've been living in a cave
for the past few years you know that
cloud computing is changing the way we
live the way we shop the way we
communicate the way we bank everything
so
our
clientele
farmers consultants
people like that are very mobile people
they don't sit in an office very much so
they are uh very much going to be
benefiting from cloud-based mobile
technology and that's what we're trying
to address you know and then if you
bring in the opportunity to do adaptive
real-time localized services
that we all in a way use when we use all
these
these great apps and all that then we
can really hopefully make some progress
so now we have adaptn.com it used to be
adopt n.cals.cornell.edu
thank god now we have adaptdn.com it's a
commercial company you now have to pay
to get an account
and but it also has allowed us to really
bring this up to a much higher level in
terms of the sophistication and it's
growing and growing
so one of the great things about cornell
and if you get involved with licensing
and you have some equity in the company
and they fund some of your research you
have to put up a slide like that you
have to disclose
that you
have some kind of a relationship with
that company so that's what i'm doing to
you right now
just in case somebody from the the
committee on
conflict of interest is in the room
um so what does adapt end up do and i'm
not going to go
into any of the details it basically
takes information on whether soil crop
and some economic factors to generate a
nitrogen rate recommendation for a
particular field at a particular time
that's basically the idea and you can
see here what all those factors are
and i'll show you some screenshots
one key component is is weather
and uh so we're using the high
resolution weather information that's
generated at the northeast climate
center on the 11th floor of broadfield
hall they've been a very critical
partner in all this
and
the high resolution part of it is very
critical because you can see this is a
a one-day
precipitation graph
and you can see for example that this
part southeastern iowa
received uh six to eight inches of
precipitation but then you go only maybe
about 10 15 kilometers to the north or
or the east and they only got maybe like
one or two inches okay so it's highly
variable if you don't have good high
resolution weather information you're
not going to be able to make a good
recommendation
in addition
we've seen that these very heavy
precipitation events defined as greater
than two inches
have increased over the past 50 years in
general we're seeing more of these heavy
precipitation events
especially in the northeast and
certainly also in the corn belt by the
way this is 1958 is the year of my birth
correlation does not equate causation
remember
so i didn't do this although i probably
did contribute to it like all of you did
okay just you know a couple of
screenshots just to give you a little
bit of a sense of the tool
you can you know
find your field on a map or you can drop
a shape file if that means anything to
you it's a gis based
file system
here's another one you can see the field
identified
and then you
basically populate that with some
information about the soil and the
management
i'll show you that for example here's uh
you indicate what soil type it is it can
by name like a honey or silt loam or it
can just be by the textural class like a
silty clay lump or something like that
and then that links it to very extensive
soil databases that we have as part of
the tool
you indicate when it's artificially
drained and things like that
you provide information on the tillage
methodology
how much residue is on the surface
how much organic matter is in the soil
because that's actually a very important
factor
crop information the the the
well it's sweet or grain or silage corn
or the maturity class is what the date
of planting
um
the population
the
rotational effects so what's the
previous crop is it sod is it soybean is
it weak or things like that and then
some other information
percent legume and all that if that's
appropriate notice also the pain here
that's you know a nice feature so if you
say manage multiple zones or multiple
fields the same way you can just click
on this and then so the same information
applies to multiple fields those kind of
things are really very important to the
user you know as researchers were like
ah whatever but it's very important to
the users so then of course how much
nitration
you have already applied so maybe a
pre-planned application or a starter
application in the midwest maybe even a
fall application
and then how much when
what's the formulation is anhydrous
ammonia is it urea
is it uan whatever
uh how much manure has been applied and
what uh
the content of nitrogen and all that in
the manures of course is we're a dairy
state very important feature of this
particular tool
and irrigation as well all right so just
to give you a little bit of of a sense a
little bit of flavor
so then you would run the model uh
currently it's all on at a large data
center actually one in virginia and one
in idaho i believe
uh this is you know these famous kind of
big data centers that's what you use
very inexpensive by the way
um so then you get a recommendation for
this particular field is 140 pounds per
acre gives you a level of confidence you
might say and it gives you a whole bunch
of background information on how much
nitrogen is currently in the soil how
much is still needed
how much has been lost so far through
rainfall especially or maybe ammonia
volatilization
how much water is is currently in the
soil how much precipitation have we
received there's even an irrigation
advisory that will be part of that next
year
and then you can enter different dates
so today's uh october what 16th
you're not going to be applying nitrogen
on corn today but you would be maybe on
june 16th and so you can enter june 16th
or any other date and you can then
generate a recommendation for that
particular date so you can go back
and
at the end of the season do what if
scenarios etc
we have some functionality that makes it
attractive to a farmer for example you
know it rolls up the
the the the
nitrogen recommendations for each field
so this farmer would have to purchase
this much night age in total so you know
some of the functionality that helps
them manage their their fields
um gives the max in the min and then it
basically allows you to look at each
field individually you can just click on
this then the whole the individual field
comes up
just nice functionalities then you may
be an agronomist or a crop consultant
who is working with multiple farmers so
they have their summaries you know so
these are multiple for for a typical
consultant is actually this may be a
hundred or so or even 500 fields
okay so try to make it attractive for
them to use
so we have the daily alerts so
instead of you doing the simulation
we do it
daily so when the new weather
information comes in
it gets run and then you get an email or
text message so you basically get a
daily update on the nitrogen status of
your field and how much nitrogen might
be needed
and you can see i mean this is when you
bring in the professional programmers it
really really looks nice
we also give a lot of
insights
try to be very transparent about what
the recommendation is based on
so for example some of these graphical
outputs and i'll show you just a couple
this is precipitation and nitrogen loss
so here's the precip and here's the
nitrogen loss
okay so this was quite wet so
this for this field lost about 80 pounds
of nitrogen because they had applied a
lot of pre-plant nitrogen
cumulative precipitation bleaching and
gases and losses
probably by next month we'll have the
n2o losses associated with that
and mineralized nitrogen and temperature
of course they're highly correlated as
well just there's more graphs i just
want to give you
a sense
so
now there's kind of this broader picture
and one i wanted to highlight and that's
walmart so walmart has
a goal to reduce their carbon footprint
by i think it's 20 million tons per year
which is really quite ambitious
walmart did an analysis of their top 10
products now keep in mind that also the
nation's largest grocer
right they're they're selling a lot of
groceries and not only the us they're a
global company as you know
revenue is equivalent to the gdp of
belgium i mean this is a big player
largest employer in the world
so when walmart says we want to reduce
our carbon footprint people start to pay
attention walmart looked at the top 10
products and found that about 45 percent
of their carbon footprint is associated
with nitrogen fertilizer for the top 10
top 100 products
which is really quite remarkable okay so
they want to
reduce that impact
so they're looking at tools like adapt
then
to be able to achieve that which we're
very happy about i was at an event last
week in bentonville and they featured
this farmer tim richter he's an iowa
farmer who's used adopt n
and he talked about his experience with
with the tool which was fortunately very
positive
for us
and there's
organizations like edf and tnc who are
really trying to promote this so what
adapt then now is doing is it's pushing
this up the supply chain so it has
agreements from kellogg's and general
mills and pepsico and coca-cola and
campbell soup
smithfield murphy brown or large pork
producer
for them
to start using these kind of tools which
is very exciting we're not quite there
yet but we're getting close
another interesting development was in
the past year
so we've had this tool out there for a
while all of a sudden guess what
monsanto
and dupont pioneer come out with an
adapt and type version
and it's like oh okay that's interesting
we weren't too happy we had just
licensed the product to this little
startup company
and um
but you know it's actually been i have
to say especially dupont pioneers
somewhat unscrupulous about these things
they they pretend like they invented
this it's like come on you guys you had
your agronomist use our tool for two
three years and we talked to your chief
agronomist you know you didn't invent it
but at least be honest about that but
you know there's actually been a real
upside to this because now all of a
sudden everybody thinks that this
approach has a lot of merit because the
big guys jumped into it
and so it's actually really benefited us
to to see these big companies getting
into this technology because it gave a
lot of credibility to what we were doing
so it's been been good
so this is currently where adopt n is
being used at least in as of july so
it's a mixture of individual farms
consultants uh we're even working with
some larger companies that are
interested in starting to use without
then now
so i just wanted to give you a little
bit of of data so what we've done
especially in new york and iowa we've
worked in other states as well is do
strip trials where
you basically
you go into farmer's fields
and you compare the adopt end
recommendation with what the grower
normally applies so it's a direct
comparison it's good for demonstration
purposes
it gives you some good data and it's
kind of like a boxing match as a winner
and a loser and so you can kind of put
it in those terms
and so i'll show you some of the results
from new york and iowa and these were
all the wonderful collaborators
so this is actually this this we kind of
summarized the data just recently so
it's 104 strip trials
um and uh so over those over three year
period
so here you see the difference in total
and applied so remember this is the
adopt end rate versus what the grower
would normally use
so in in the vast majority of the cases
in 87 out of 104 the adopt-in
recommendation was lower
okay so we
and so less nitrogen was supplied which
is a good thing for the environment in a
few cases we recommended more and that
was in mostly in 2003 when we had a very
wet growing season and a higher rate was
justified
okay
so this is the delta yield
so
in most cases when we said put less
nitrogen on but they were able to on the
average achieve the same yield that's a
good thing
the same yield with less nitrogen so
less environmental impact
and then in a few cases where we said
put more on
that needs to be justified by higher
yields
and that was in general the case in most
cases
the yields were significantly higher
when we said put a little bit more
nitrogen on so it was justified most of
the nitrogen still ended up in the plant
which is good
and then this is the delta profit
and you can see that in the vast
majority of cases in about four out of
five cases we were able to show greater
profits
so what that means is that's a win-win
scenario
we can we can say to farmers look we can
we can increase your profits
on the average
and you can decrease the amount of
nation that you apply so limiting the
environmental impact and basically by
being more precise
so here's some of the summary data i
just wanted to point out so here you can
see the and fertilizer inputs for iowa
new york the three years
so we always were able to reduce the
inputs except
in 2013 in new york when it was wet we
said put on the average put a little bit
more on but on the average
we were able to significantly reduce the
amount of nitrogen
that goes in into onto the field and
into the environment
uh the yields were in a way positive
primarily for those
for the cases where we said a little bit
more and the profit on the average about
35 dollars per acre increase in profit
so
that's positive
i'll skip the wisconsin data
so this is basically the bottom line so
if we can do increased profits reduced
environmental inputs and we did some
model simulations to look at the
leaching and nitrous oxide losses that's
a good thing so we feel really good
about that it's not perfect but it's a
lot better than what's out there
and you know we feel that transparency
and insights even though it's a
commercial product is really valuable
still you know farmers and consultants
like that
and it provides incentives for better
management we've seen a lot of farmers
who are looking at the losses that they
had from say an early season application
and then they get a lot of rain and they
lost like in that in their graph they
lost 80 pounds and so they're doing the
math and they say boy i lost about 50 an
acre maybe i should change my strategy
so being transparent and informative
helps with that
okay this is my last slide i i won't
mention each of these people
individually but we've had some great
collaborators it's been a great team
effort
and
we're very grateful for the multiple
funding sources
thank you
yeah that's a good question the um
it's it's actually relatively difficult
to work with individual farmers that's
one of the things we found out there
there are some very high maintenance to
a lot of correspondence so we're trying
to focus a little bit more on the larger
companies trying to so for example
if you can get say cargill or general
mills to support that we're also working
with walmart directly we're asking
walmart why don't you sponsor
you know uh 50 000 acres of the use of
adopt-in
so that's the kind of the way we we try
to do this
you know people need to get used to the
idea that they have to pay for these
services if you do a soil nitrate test
and you send it to a lab you have to pay
for that as well
these cloud computational tools it costs
money to develop them and to
maintain them
so but the cost is relatively low it's
depending on the size it's you know
generally in sort of the 152 dollars per
acre if it's a little bit larger
operation so it's really you know and we
have proved a profit of about 35.
but yeah if we can get more more
sponsoring then that would be good and
one of the funny things about knights
and fertilizations it's it's heavily
it's very political and very state-based
so if you come up with a tool that kind
of transcends all these individual
because every state has their own
recommendation system it's really kind
of bizarre when you think about it's a
leftover from many years ago and when
you come in with a tool that says you
know
you know state boundaries don't matter
anymore because we account for
variations in soil and climate and all
that uh there's uh you
meet some resistance it's very
interesting especially in the scientific
community
yeah
so with that i won't talk more about
that because i can
talk for hours
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu